CONTENDERS IN THE NATIONAL
HOCKEY LEAGUE.
SO IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHERE   AWE.
OLEKSIAK UNSUCCESSFULUL.
HOME OF
>> Jamie: THIS STARTS RIGHT
FROM THE ENTRY A LITTLE DELAY
THE PLAY.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
HE WAS HANDLING IT.
HE CAN SKATE IT IN.
BUT THIS
>> Gord: PRETTY QUICK FROM THE
LINESMEN SCOTT TERRY, MICHELLETS
.
NORRIS WILL   JADEN SCHWARTZ KNS
IT AWAY FROM JARNKROK WHOSE N
THAT.
>> Jamie: A LITTLE BIT OF A
STATUE OF LIBERTY
PICKED OFF BY STUTZLE.
STUTZLE DROPS IT OFF. GET IT DOY
FORSBERG.
ADAM LARSSON COMES BACK TO TAKE
IT AWAY. POSITION.
AND RI
JORDAN EBERLE BRINGS IT BACK
AROUND T T FOR
ZACH
TKACHUK.
GETS A TIP ON ADVERSITY.
CHANGING WAVERS AND
ORGANIZATIONS AND YOU WILL A THE
UNCERTAINTY WITH THE COVID STOPD
CONFIDENCE AT THE NATIONAL
HOCKEY LEAGUE LEVEL WITH HIS
FIFTH GOAL TONIGHT.
BACK INTO THE CORNER WITH IT.
BACK IT GOES.
A PIECE OF THAT.
KNOCKED IT JUST WIDE. WERE ALL M
F
THAT SHOT.
WIN THE DRAW.ASSED.
EBERLE HAS DROPPED IT BACK.
THEN STEPS IANN.
THE NIFTY LITTLE PLAY.
14 GOALS -- THE REDIRECT BY
DONATO.
FOLIGNO TO SAN JOSE WHO RETAINED
THE MOORE SALARY, GOT A PICK,
NORRIS TO CHABOT.